hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's been a few weeks since our last
meet up but now we have the map changes
for the week ahead of chapter 2 of
season 2 week 5 some interesting finds
this week as always to support this
series please think about using code and
amaru in the shop don't worry if you
can't I'm just glad you're here all the
same so sit your butt down for 10
minutes forget about how the real world
is falling apart and let's go through
all the map changes on fortnight battle
royale Island
[Music]
this week we are starting with the brand
new vehicle of the chopper and right
away I made sure I had a shiny pink
chopper to impress all the single ladies
this thing is here for travel purposes
and makes this series so much easier to
make thank you so much epic also have
you noticed the Easter Egg the vehicles
horn is flight of the Valkyries if
you've seen Apocalypse Now you'll get
the reference if you don't you should
ask your parents to scratch that ask
your grandparents I feel old while we're
here the next myth chases episode will
be all about the helicopters so if you
have a myth for us to bust please put
them in the comments below and upvote
your favorites the weirder the better
anyway let's get to the rig
holy shizzle Batman the rig is a shell
of its former glory blown to pieces
annihilated by this explosion the PIO
eye is completely different earlier in
the week I visited to look around and
this is the room tn tina lives in and
works in by looks of it if her name
doesn't give it away she's responsible
for creating explosives and she lives on
an oil tanker those two do not go
together well I think it's safe to say
that T and Tina caused all this
devastation these are the remains of her
room and it looks like it's the
epicenter of the boom other changes here
include the tugboats coming over to save
the remains of the platform and in case
you're wondering the room with all the
superhero artifacts and the movie
memorabilia it's still here but look the
base has been claimed once again as a
shadow location banners can be found
nearby too this feeds into the theory
that each week we unlock a new character
in the battle paths and then vote which
side they fight for we ultimately
dictate how the island is redesigned so
far both Brutus and T and Tina have
switched to team shadow Brutus's change
was like a villain in a Bond film where
our team tina destroyed her research
accidentally which sent her down this
dark path
hang on a ghost the bad guys or a shadow
the bad guys I'm still completely unsure
one last thing to note here is the oil
spill under the platform this could be
nothing at all or it could play into the
storyline the slurpy swamp and the murky
oil combining to create something
similar to I don't know
venom maybe damn it I like that I'm
calling it now this may create something
like venom a creature which is both
oil-based and also super powered by the
Slurpee waters this could be awesome
venom crossover in 2020 confirmed so the
next update the character impact in the
storyline is the buff cap dude I'm not
saying his real name okay he has to earn
it the hench [ __ ] bloke I'm getting
sidetracked to preempt this change I've
looked around the boat and you should do
it too because this place is full of
details there's a room that's a gym
there's an awesome deck office but the
best room must be the toilet a cat
litter tray are you now picturing a
human using it me to look on the wall we
see his arch nemesis and of course it's
the Doge moving on one of the first
things I did after logging on after the
update was to fly over the chair truck
which we've been following for ever I
knew it was turning into retail row but
when I got there it wasn't here I was
Shuker of course I found it and look
where it is it's by the bunker where
could it be going I attempted to land on
the truck and I regret my decision
over the last 15 weeks we've seen the
chairs collected at the docks and slowly
painstakingly slowly followed this road
all the way to its current location any
guesses as to where this vehicle will
stop on the flip side of this was the
pallet truck driven from the log jam
factory over three weeks this time we
watched that one travel in the opposite
direction first passing the tree nursery
before causing an accident in the
mountains and then passing through fake
happy hamlet
I mean misty Meadows and currently sits
here where is it going
what building will be built from these
precious pallets do you think the two
trucks are going to meet up
oh and as a side note the truck that was
on the bridge in season 1 is now here
could be nothing could be something it's
likely moving out of the way for the
chair truck we shall see here's a good
one
remember when chapter 2 began and we
found potential but watch locations well
one of those was at the farm
a modest shed was being constructed out
of nowhere
it's now complete it looks finished but
I'll keep an eye on it all the same and
now we have the potential story linked
to the season the eagle-eyed have you
noticed something last week a canoe with
a gold chair inside what could this be
going back to the agency we noticed a
chair was missing from the meeting room
and not just any chair this was my
decision
the man of gold after four weeks of
holding meetings here it was stolen and
carted across the lake to a hidden
vehicle in the bushes and this week
things have progressed the canoe and
chair have vanished but wait we can
track them down due to the muddy tracks
the canoe is now hidden in the bushes
but the vehicle has raced away once
again following those tire tracks we
caught up with the culprit in salty
springs hidden away under the cover is
that golden chair and I'm not sure if
the Rope is important or not hang on
I've seen that robbed today over in the
yard that's one of meows Jim ropes is
this a coincidence or is this vehicle
stealing items from all the season's
characters I've ventured down to
Brutus's cave to see what his room held
and his sword and sleeping arrangements
were still intact I'm probably
overthinking this so where will the
culprit take this golden chair it looks
like it's heading over to the beach or
maybe the destroyed castle on the hill
you should subscribe so you don't miss
another exciting episode
with all the helicopters in the game
there was one place we had to check a
pleasant park and oh yes it's true the
helipad underground has been revealed
drawing back the grass the hidden layer
is now open to all last week the
henchmen began spawning above-ground
which was a definite surprise also many
people noted that when loading into the
map pleasant wouldn't render correctly
and how could we use a helipad that was
underground well we were right in the
end and now this snug hole is perfect
for my pink chopper dad jokes
here's another noteworthy change to the
map over by Ferris Bueller's house just
look for yourself it's a complete mess
here's the backstory should you need to
know it in season one this house was a
clear Easter Egg to the film Ferris
Bueller's Day Off in which Pharisees
friend accidentally pushed his father's
Ferrari out of a garage window and onto
the ground below to shadow this
fortnight's red car did the same and
that's where it stayed for weeks last
time we met up a crane was sent in to
pull up the crushed car and just when
everything looked to be going well it
all came crashing down quite literally I
hope we see another bigger crane built
to pull this crane out and you never
know by the end of season 10 we could
have 100 vehicles piled up here
a few smaller things to note around the
map over in retail row where the ghost
and shadow offices back onto one another
the picture on the wall is finally
visible on console let's take a look see
any clues here last week new posters
could be found around the map I suggest
you keep an eye on these this week
because Deadpool may be targeting these
and speaking of Deadpool for the first
time we've seen him on the map he was
there in the reveal of the chopper look
how good that skin looks you know we
have to have a 100 person meet up with
Deadpool sometime it'll be epic to visit
last week's main question we all know
about Graham the genome living in the
radio tower and last time we met up we
discovered his twin brother held in a
secret underground facility by the
dastardly misfit bears back then I asked
you to name him here's the top three
answers in third place was Jerome the
genome I thought I was gonna win but
then the next suggestion stole second
place and caused a little drama
that's your alert anyway many of you
want to call him keemstar I wonder why
but the winning name of Graham's twin
brother is a beauty everyone I'd like to
introduce you to Gandalf the genome what
a great name in fact let's use all these
three suggestions this is Gandalf
keemstar Jerome the genome it rolls off
the tongue it really does nothing has
happened down here anyway this week so
we'll leave things how they are or not
and we'll come back next week and we
can't finish the video without
celebrating something almost two years
in the making
we now have loadouts man this is great
here's my him a built for those who
asked it to know it I'm also planning to
make builds for all my limited edition
skins by the way when we do our
community meetups it's a great idea to
have a default character a prebuilt
but we'll talk about that once my
streams come back let's put a pin in it
and just when I was finishing the video
I decided to go on one last aerial
journey around to see if I could spot
anything else and look at this the iron
man began to move check him out he's
going for a hike he's a man on a mission
and I've ran tests this is clinically
proven Dancing with rowdy
pikemen gives us easy wins it's true
it's damn true now that's how you end a
map change video I think we are done all
the changes in fortnight season 2 week 5
expect more Deadpool content to be added
before our next Meetup I'm not a big fan
of spoiling things so I'll just leave
that there on screen are the legends who
continue to use my code over the last
baron two weeks of fortnight content I
hugely appreciate you if you'd like to
join the legands roll call please use
code atom arrow in the store and send me
a Twitter DM we've proof of your
purchase I'm Adam grenade over there
thank you very much for your time please
make sure you've written a myth below
for the chopper episode of myth Chase is
coming this week much appreciated
thank you mango FN for the gold
playstation grenade logo it looks pretty
cool I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time
[Music]